台股近期剧烈震荡
现行处置制度
因为线缩交易流动性
引发立委王世坚
还有知名的交易员巨人杰等人接连抨击
而面对外界指引声浪
证交所在今天傍晚
急急召开了调整处置机制相关措施的说明记者会
由副总杜惠娟正式对外说明
那我们综合考量了近期市场的变化
证交所这边呢
修正了处置有价证券的处置期间
撮合作业的时间
以及公布助益交易资讯的标准
股民们注意了有鉴于近期股市震荡剧烈
现行储置制度限缩交易流动性
证交所3号临时召开记者会
宣布修订公布助益及储置有价证券相关规定
并从8月10号起正式实施
第一项就调整储置的期间
那第一次跟第二次呢
含以上呢
招发布处置的有价证券
那处置期间呢
修改为5个营业日
原来呢是10个营业日
除了关禁币时间大幅缩短
一般处置股改为5个营业日
当冲过高处置也从原先的12个营业日
缩短为7个营业日
当然这个就会有加速短线的这个流动性
因为毕竟这一次
各股在末顿不理性的下跌的同时
也是被相關的儲置交易限制
造成缺乏流動性的問題
我想在整個儲置措施修正之後
我認為對於漲不過大或是跌不過大的個股來講
短線就是有機會價格進入穩定
儲置期間縮短之外
撮合頻率也由現行的5分鐘或20分鐘
統一加速制約每2分鐘就撮合一次
同時證交所也同步放寬
高价股的注意股票认定标准
并建立每半年定期检视机制
至于会不会研议接轨国际的盘中熔断机制
建姜所回应不考虑
因为台股不像美股没有涨跌幅限制
或是韩国美日涨跌幅30%
需要以熔断来因应剧烈变动
另外分析师则提醒
待新智上路后还需持续观察
是否有助稳定交易秩序
记者黄友柔邱文杰台北采访报道
财经焦点再来关心到
不受日韩股走势偏弱影响
台股八月开红盘表现一枝独秀
今天开低走高买盘敲进
最高来到43,784点
上涨超过600点
而盘面的焦点聚焦在记忆体PCB
还有被动元件等族群
国际再度亮灯
电子全职股当中
联发科日月光也都亮灯涨停
激励加群指数中场是上涨了266点
收在43,386点
成交金额大约是8000多亿元
来看到今天三大法人的筹码动向
外资今天是调节了191亿元
投薪是唯一站在買方加碼了210億元
而自營商則是賣超了206億元
再來看到今天盤面上焦點的個股族群被動元件族群是持續的重回反彈的走勢國聚還有日電帽都是亮燈漲停帶動今天有9檔的被動元件族群
都是強勢的攻上漲停
其中指標部國聚是連續兩個交易日拉漲停板
今天收在552塊錢
日電帽也是來到137.5塊錢的漲停價位
另外看到的是載版三雄的部分表現也非常的強勁
今天有兩檔攻上漲停板
星星還有請說是分別來到865元和698元
再來看到高價股的部分
今天也是有17檔的帶量攻上漲停
其中股王信華是來到了15975元
等於一張就可以賺進145塊錢
還有川湖的部分
今天也是收在8635元的漲停價位
再來關心到台股7月震盪劇烈
月線下跌超過3000點
ETF的投資熱度也是持續升溫
而根據最新統計顯示
全市場受益人數突破百萬大關的ETF
已經擴增至6檔
除了傳統市值型高股型ETF
主動式的ETF也是跟著崛起
來看到這個6檔高人器的ETF部分
0050目前是躍增了32萬人的這個
受益人數來到了356萬人
還有0056的部分也是躍增了9.1萬人
來到166萬人
還有00878的部分跟00919人器也是非常高
受益人数分别来到了162万人
还有138万人
再来看到的是主动市也有双雄日榜
包括了是00403A还有00918A
目前的这个受益人数也是突破百万人
分别来到104万人还有100万人
而随着时事进入8月
华南投顾就看好
若是联准会9月不升息
台股最快在第四季上看5万点
而选股方向建议是CCL
记忆体被动元件还有电力等相关族群
指数4万点短底确立
震荡主体之后有望继续上工
台股延续上周反弹气势
在8月的第一个交易日
虽然开低但随即就走高
一度上涨超过600点
台积电股价疲弱
好在还有二哥联发科撑盘
开盘没多久就锁涨停
日月光投控也亮灯
基本上就是可以确定
台股的这一波的修正结束
上个礼拜大概39000点
到40,000点这个地方
应该就台股确定是台股的底部区
那只不过在选股上面
从上个礼拜五的这个无差别的大涨
那今天呢是有很明显的有特定的族群呢
这个带领这个大盘上工
我们预计这个未来的区间呢
大概是在月线大概四万四千点
这附近跟四万点这边来回震荡主体
那我们对第四季的行情还是很看好
国际连续两个交易日亮灯
市值守住赵元大关
带动被动元件族群再度吹响反攻号角
华兴科金山店秘望时股价齐阳
记忆体三雄华邦店南亚科望虹
也涌入大量买盘推升股价走高
CPU族群包含联雅
颇弱位光盛表现同样强劲
另外千金谷更是盘面最大亮点
谷王姓华谷后川湖都在盘中早早亮红灯
我们台股还有其他的一些好族群
比如像是散热族群或是细光子族群
7月份在经历了大震荡之后
这些族群目前为止
开始有个回稳
所以第一個為什麼今天我們台股
有個獨強的條件在裡面
原因是我們基本上除了台積電之外
還有很多還蠻強勁的一些產業
也剛好搭上這個AI的時代
這個健康的盤是
本來最好就是不要執掌台積電一家而是基於有有我們在這個地方跟著一起輿入均戰從CPU進入到ASIC客製化晶片台積電合作供應商同樣獲得資金青睞
專家認為台股第三季拉回收證屬於正常現象
目前指跌訊號陸續浮現
預計大盤在箱形整理後有望繼續上工
記者黃友柔 邱文傑 台北採訪報導
產業焦點來關心到記憶體供應持續吃緊
大幅推升硬體成本
苹果最新財報雖然開紅盤
但是坦言目前正面臨到百年一遇的記憶體價格洪水
而且短期內恐怕無法緩解
而苹果先前就傳出將會擴大D-RAM採購來源
另外中國的D-RAM龍頭常新科技LPDDR6記憶體
預計會在今年年底之前量產
將與SK海力士來做競爭
而來看到今天台韓記憶體廠股價呈現兩樣型
受到这个长新科技
LPDDR6即将量产的消息影响
SK海力士还有三星电子的股价
今天是下挫都来到8%的幅度
不过看到反观台湾的记忆体概念股
则是受回基本面改善
还有题材面的助攻之下
今天包括南亚科华邦店
望宏金豪科还有华东
都是有资金买盘涌入
是刷一整排亮灯涨停
近期机体族群走势剧烈之际
日本Nandflash大厂凯霞宣示将寄出高达8000亿日元的库藏股买回措施
周一股价大涨5.7%
再在显示公司勘讨产业长期发展
产业界人士也都普遍对于机体产业展望乐观
认为后续价格走势还渴望逐步上扬
美国的前八大的云端服务业者
其实都陆续的调高了资本支出金额
对于2026年下半年乃至于整个2027年的记忆体的需求
尤其是HyperMemory乃至扩散到一般的标准型Dram都还是会增加的
观察周一台股盘面记忆体族群一片红通通
受到产业供需紧俏试况持续激励
让族群成为盘面焦点
开盘不久指标股华邦店南亚科望红金豪科等五党个股强势表态
亮灯直冲涨停价位
反观韩国股市方面
身为国内全职股的两大记忆体原厂
SK海力士与三星电子
跌幅却超过8%
罕见让台韩记忆体股价表现呈现两样勤
韩国股市呢
经常在上礼拜是大涨
市值接近20%嘛
然后那当然说三星和海力士
经常占韩国的全职超过50%
涨多之后呢
基本上变成说这些全职股
韩国全职股其实开始出现休息
因为像今天台积电一样
台湾的记忆体
基本上你说全职嘛算
但是基本上它不是一个大全
不是一个主要全职
所以他们其实今天也还是持续处在一个
估值修复的状态
所以变成说他们会出现一个
比较连续的一个强劲的一个公司
不过分析师也提醒
尽管产业基本面持续向上
短线上仍需留意涨多拉回风险
接下来除了观察
记忆体报价能否持续上扬外
紧接着华邦店法说会将于6日登场
所释出的事况与未来展望
都将成为产业重要风向球
记者洪晋雄如洗台北采访报道
再来看到IBM日前宣布了正式跨入量子优势时代
代表量子电脑已经能够完成传统电脑难以处理的预算
而IBM执行长乐观将公司在量子电脑领域的地位
堪比回答在GPU的先发地位
预期将成为公司重要的成长引擎同时也预期至2030年相關市場規模有望達到1兆美元而台廠其實也早早布局相關領域
渴望同步搶食商機
來看到今天台廠相關的概念股
包括金寶 廣達 鴻海 還有人寶
都是早早打入相關的供應鏈
甚至成立了量子的國家隊
來看到今天相關的股價也是有所表態
金寶近陽超過半根停板 漲幅5.83%
來到31.75塊錢
广达也是上涨了1.72%的幅度
来到296.5块钱
而鸿海跟人宝也是在盘上表现
而除了量子电脑有最新的突破之外
科技大厂其实在下半年也有其他的好消息
包括外资高深就点出了最新AI伺服器的趋势
首先是Agentic AI带动伺服器的需求不断的成长
还有Asic AI伺服器的商机是越来越大
而这个围影也持续扩大在美国CSP客户的版图
看好AI伺服器的产品组合持续升级
而电子代工大厂渴望的是
受惠挥达下半年Vera Ruben最新机会的领域持续扩张
还有量产同步出货
来看到今天微影的股价是亮灯涨停来到5925元
而高盛更是直接喊出目标价值万元
另外看到伪创的部分表现也很强劲
是上涨了超过半根停板
涨幅5.68%的幅度来到186块钱
还有应叶达也是上涨了3.4%的幅度
以63.9块钱做手
一有问题就会打开ChadGPT Gemini
这些回答背后都需要AI伺服器高速运转提供算力
微影受惠于通用伺服器与ASIC AI伺服器和GPU三大成长动能
让高盛把目标价由原先的7147元一口气调升到1万元
消息也激励微影三日股价供上涨停板
收在5925元改写历史新高
它不只是把获利预估调高
它是连本益比都一起往上调
才会出现1万块这个数字
所以接下来你就要看
七八九月的营收状况
就是甚至第四季的营收状况
有没有真的上来
那特别是获利
有没有真的跟着有明显的要升
才能搭配上它的股价
分析师认为后续毛利率表现是观察重点
高盛预估美国主要云端服务供应商
2026到2028年资本支出
年复合成长率可达到21%
持续扩大AI基础建设布局
唯影凭借长期投入伺服器研发与工程资源
有望打入更多美国大型云端客户供应链
带动2026到2028年营收年复合成长率达到32%
庞大的需求也让台湾7月的出口表现非常亮眼
台湾到目前为止的出口其实都非常的畅旺
上半年的出口我想已经突破了新高
主基础刚刚也才把第二季的经济成长
其实上调了两个百分点
所以都显示其实台湾在上半年的出口真的非常畅旺
中金燕表示电子零组件与光学产业
成为支撑台湾制造业扩张的重要动能
另外法人也看好
音叶达在伺服器业务
持续成为营运成长主轴
预估到了2027年
音叶达伺服器营收占比
渴望突破6成
台厂也有望进一步扩大全球市场版图
记者许又娟方秀成台北采访报导